and we'll thank you for the intro
tough start to the morning here I've
been in statistics and gaussian
regression talks all morning so my
head's head's getting a little full but
uh while everybody's sitting down I'll
I'll just point everybody out this is
contact info for me in case you want to
get a hold of me uh and I did push the
slides up on SlideShare so my name is
Mike potaro I
I'm going to start off this talk since
we're talking about Hardware slightly
different for me I'm usually giving
talks about code Python and things like
that but I'm currently working as a big
data architect to Dell
so there was some interest about
hardware for high performance uh
analytics and I figured I'm going to try
and squeeze this into a short session
you know we've got about 40 minutes I
can't cover everything so what I'm
hoping is that I can go deep enough
to help you understand some of the
trade-offs involved when you're building
mainly clusters but also just picking
out workstations get you to the point
where you're intelligent enough to know
which questions to ask and which ones
don't matter and frankly to learn from
what other people are doing there's a
there's kind of a body and knowledge
here around clusters and high
performance Computing that doesn't
always make it out to soft to developers
particularly in the data science space
um so my Approach I kind of struggled
with this I wasn't sure how to do this
talk
um because I realized I'm dealing a lot
more with programmers and usually I'm
talking to people that live and breathe
this stuff and know it better than I do
in some cases so my Approach was let's
spend a little time talking about why we
want to look at the hardware then I'm
going to start with an overview of a
production cluster design something
we're selling now as a product and then
I'll go backwards and take it up take it
apart and look at the individual
components and explain some of the
trade-offs that were involved in the
design
my day job I'm a principal architect for
Big Data Solutions I'm actually in
engineering so I'm not a field
consultant with customers I think
architect is becoming like a systems
analyst these days everybody's an
architect uh but my job is to to design
clusters and document them in the form
of what we call reference architectures
or blueprints that our customers can
then use as the basis to implement
something my background is data
warehousing data integration and super
Computing when I was much much younger
so I used to deal with cn4tran these
days I'm pretty much a python guy I
really haven't written Fortran in about
15 or 20 years and I dabble and see but
I wouldn't call myself a c programmer
uh so as I get into this uh one of the
things I wanted to ask as I'm going into
the talk uh I'm going to talk a little
bit about why I consider the hardware
but one of the things I want to ask is
for the people in the room here uh I'm
making some sort of an assumption that
you understand Hadoop or spark or
parallel processing is everybody okay
with that assumption for now the other
thing I was going to say about q a uh
I'll try and leave time at the end for Q
a I think we'll have enough time but if
I say something that just knocks you out
of your turn you have no idea what I
said you know interrupt me ask a
question ask me to clarify something
don't sit there being confused because
there's a lot of acronyms here
um so
from the top down I mean one of the
questions is why do we really really
want to ask about the hardware what do
we want to think about it one reason is
the choice of Hardware actually has some
pretty big impacts both on your wallet
and on the performance of your programs
um personally I've I've spent my career
dealing with both hardware and software
I think understanding something about
the hardware helps you write software
um there are there are people here like
Andy that really understand the
low-level details of the processors and
optimize things but in general
it helps to understand what's on iron
you're running on uh another issue it
comes up quite often hosting things in
the cloud whether it's just using
servers at Rackspace or some ISP or
using the Amazon cloud or one of the
other ones there are a lot of people
that either can't put their stuff on
those machines or just they're not
willing to it you know there are some
people that feel strongly they're in the
retail sales business and they don't
want to run their infrastructure on
Amazon because Amazon competes with them
they feel strongly about that
also you'll hear horror stories about
operating costs going so too high it
depends on what you're doing but you can
run up a pretty big Bill if you're not
paying attention and there are guys that
actually use algorithms to optimize
their machine usage on Amazon it's kind
of like a little niche market and you
know sometimes you just need the
performance there are trade-offs when
the machines are remote and you're
always running over a remote Network
sometimes you just need local
performance
um another killer reason becomes more
important when you're in the Big Data
space data is heavy so you don't want to
move a lot of data around a local
cluster usually has persistent data so
you fire up a job your day your data is
there when you're done it's still there
you don't have to worry about sucking it
all out and shutting down a cluster and
when the data gets big enough it's
expensive so that's really why we're
talking about Hardware there are a lot
of other reasons but
here's the problem with hardware and as
I said I spent a lot of time working in
both of these fields
the problem with any sort of Big Data
Hardware is there's a lot of options
servers processors gpus you're dealing
with Drive you're dealing with
networking you're dealing with jargon
and acronyms that have been developed
over the course of 20 years and you're
dealing with a lot of misleading
information you'll see recommendations
on Hadoop nodes on the internet Google
Hadoop Hardware recommendations you'll
see something six years out of date
and a lot of these blog posts aren't
dated which is a personal net of mine
you know blog posts should be dated so
that we can put them in historical
context but anyhow there's a lot of
confusion there's a lot of pieces
most of our customers are interested in
something that is going to work they
want results they understand the
technology but they're interested in
performance they're concerned with
reliability they want something that's
predictable they do con they're
concerned with costs so cost management
comes into play but in general they're
looking for something that's proven and
tested
uh so rather than a set of tools they're
often asking us for a finished product
the work that I do is between these two
primarily I work on things we call a
reference architecture it's effectively
a blueprint so when a customer is
looking for a Hadoop cluster or spark
cluster there are some documents
available that describe how to go about
and build one and it's tested
configurations we have products where we
actually test that configuration in a
lab but it's it's tested we have an idea
of the software we can make
recommendations at a low level on bios
settings and so on
but it's a blueprint so it's not a fixed
configuration normally somebody will
pick that up and then we'll start
tweaking it
the secret to these architectures I know
I'm giving away the dirty secret of all
the hardware guys but the the secret to
any of these architectures it's not that
one's better or worse it's all about
balance you're dealing with a price
constraint you have a performance
constraint you have a particular
application you're running and you're
trying to balance that all and come up
with something that catches all those uh
catches all those constraints
but behind the scenes you're always
worrying about fault zones because when
you add this many machines you will have
a problem where you're going to have
failures and you have to account for
them
the way I was going to handle this is to
go backwards I'm probably going to go
over here and point because uh for this
picture I just want to point some things
out but other than I'll be back to the
computer
I just finished up a project we call the
Dell in memory Appliance for clutter
Enterprise
um it's it's a new offering for us and
then it's a packaged Hadoop cluster
that's been optimized for large memory
Footprints and I'm just going to point
out the pieces here in the rack and then
we're going to go back and kind of drill
into the individual choices this
particular system it's a Hadoop cluster
you can get up to four racks most
customers will buy in the beginning just
one Rack or two racks and then they
scale out these machines down here at
the bottom of those three racks are the
data nodes so these are the ones that
are doing most of the Hadoop processing
the first rack over here has four nodes
at the top that act as infrastructure
for Hadoop so this is the hadoops both
the distributed file system and a
processing platform so the name node and
the directory services for the file
system are running on these nodes one of
these boxes is set up to interface to
the outside world so that's the basic
physical layout of the club of the racks
there's a monitor in here every rack has
Network switches at the top the machines
in each rack are going to connect up to
those Network switches there are no
cables here because it we didn't have
the picture when I was getting the
presentation ready I think we have one
now but these machines All Connect up to
what we call a Topper rack switch and
there's pair of switches at the top of
every one of those racks and then the
four racks in turn the switches at the
top of those racks connect to two more
switches here and they are what we call
the aggregations which are the cluster
switch so the four racks go up in a tree
to the top
and then these units here it's not
really visible but these are management
switches they're there to do SSH into
the machines and remote access so that
somebody can manage it the switches at
the top are the data Network so that's
kind of the crash course in the physical
uh layout of this cluster in terms of
what's in here in practice behind the
scenes this is a crash course in the
specs I I don't want you to get the
impression that I'm trying to promote
huge numbers here but I just wanted to
put it into perspective
the servers we used are Dell r720s which
are what we call two rack units high if
I went back to this slide here
these racks are 42 units high those
servers are two units the switches are
one unit each if you haven't been in the
machine room this is just the lingo we
use
So within here we use the r720 which is
two rack units each of those machines
has dual Intel xeons so they're Xeon E5
2620s which in kind of normal language
translates into they're all Intel Ivy
Bridge processors they have 10 cores in
each processor they have 25 Mega Megs of
cash and clock rates on these are about
two and a half gigahertz
uh every one of those machines is set up
with 384 gigs of memory which is at the
high end of what you will see in a
Hadoop cluster
that's because this particular machine
was designed for spark and Impala which
tend to do which tend to use memory very
efficiently Hadoop itself wants to do a
lot of disk i o the machines in there
are running DDR3 1866
Mega transactions per second storage in
each one of those nodes is 48 terabytes
it's set up with 12 four terabyte disks
every machine has two 10 gigabit
Ethernet interfaces that go into the
network and we actually Bond those two
interfaces to give us a
kind of a logical link that's just shy
of 20 gigabits
and then there's a management Network in
terms of scaling on the cluster
you can go between four data nodes up to
12 20 and 44 has kind of a sliding scale
depending on and you can also buy just
four data nodes and add them over time
in terms of total memory you're starting
at you're starting at 1500 gigabytes and
you're going all the way up to just shy
at 30 gigabytes of memory so this is a
large memory footprint cluster in terms
of storage
you're looking at anything between 176
terabytes up to
petabytes that is raw storage so I
haven't done any fudging on those
numbers to account for operating system
or Hadoop replication in practice you're
going to use you're going to have about
a third of that in terms of usable
storage for Hadoop because it's going to
make three copies of the data
cores
you're starting with 80 cores you're
going up to 880 at the high end for the
cluster so you've got a reasonable
amount of CPU processing every one of
those cores is running at two gigahertz
and it fits in between one and four
recks
and as I said the reason I'm giving you
these specs is I want to now jump in a
little bit look behind the scenes at
what drove some of these decisions and
help you understand some of the some of
the trade-offs here
I can't quote prices on a video but uh
uh how much power
that particular cluster needs about 30
amps at 208 volts for every rack it's
very very dense configuration talk to me
about pricing later I'm not going to get
in trouble quoting pricing on a video
because
it'll go viral trust me
also I'm not a sales guy
um
the first I'm going to jump ahead again
let's talk about servers for the moment
because that's one of the first
decisions in terms of servers
there are a lot of choices in the
industry
generally we're looking at three types
of servers uh the top right hand corner
there is a four socket server it takes
up four years of Rackspace more commonly
and it has four Xeon processors in it
that type of machine is real popular for
big databases things like Oracle things
like large Microsoft Exchange servers I
think it's most important feature other
than four sockets is you can get those
boxes with big memory Footprints like
six terabytes is reasonable main memory
it's a single box most of your
applications will run on it without any
fancy parallelization other than basic
threading
uh the downside is those boxes tend to
be kind of expensive the four socket
architecture has this little premium on
it because you have four CPUs and a big
memory footprint over on the left is
something called a blade chassis
um all vendors have equivalents to these
These are the Dell model numbers this is
the m1000d
it's a fairly large chassis so it's 10U
and it has slots that you can plug in
all these different modules so you can
plug in processors memory storage and
kind of Juggle them around and there's a
lot of common Logic on the back plane
that connects these units together these
are great for flexibility for companies
that are doing virtualization and have
different types of applications they
love these blades you pay a premium for
that flexibility
the 2u to you two socket servers are the
ones that are incredibly popular with
what we call scale out vendors or scale
out Computing so a lot of the cloud
companies whether it's if you look at
I'm not quoting Dell customers but if
you look at a Google a Yahoo a Microsoft
running Bing and anybody that runs a
large scale out Computing organization
they use lots of the same type of
machine and they tend to replicate their
configuration over and over again so
these two socket
two socket machines take up to you and
we have a class of those machines that
actually has local storage so the
pictures here are two different
variations of a Dell r730 this one has
12 three and a half inch drives that are
hot swappable right in the front of the
chassis this has 24 two and a half inch
spindles
the two socket servers the ones that are
almost universally used for Hadoop and
Spark
they're pretty good value they have a
lot of storage in each machine the blade
servers you can put some storage in them
but they're usually attached to network
attached storage the four socket servers
you can see you got a bunch of two and a
half inch drives there I'm not counting
them but I think there's about as many
two and a half inch drives as that four
socket as there is in the 720 below
they're normally plugged into a network
attached storage or a director attached
storage array with Hadoop and spark
people love to have their local storage
on every single node
so those are the common machines
the
the next page here is just a whole bunch
of texts that more or less covers what I
just said it this is I do a lot of
presentations like this so you know four
socket blade servers two socket scale
out the two socket stuff is what we're
almost always looking at in terms of
Hadoop and Spark
drill down a little now I'm gonna get
geeky guys
um when we look at the Dual socket stuff
the basic architecture of the Intel dual
socket processors you have two
processors each processor has four
connections to memory you can put three
memory chips in each I guess you'd call
it a bank from one of the better
description and there's this high speed
interconnect between the processors
called the qpi the quick path
interconnect
the latest generation of Intel stuff is
known as the grantly architecture that's
describing the socket organization
and the code name for the processors
themselves or Haswell Top Line specs we
can get 18 cores in each one of those
processors today
um
they have four channels of ddr4 which
lets you go up to 2133 Mega transactions
per second they're fast
some specs on the qpi the basic idea is
you have two sockets memory on each
socket you have an interconnect between
the processors the memory isn't really
flat it's a little tricky Pro memory
that's local to a processor can can be
accessed quicker than the memory that's
on the other processor so technically
your memory is divided into two pieces
this bet these Banks and those Banks the
quick path interconnect lets a processor
make a reference to the memory on the
external on the other chip and it also
is used a lot to handle cache
synchronization between those processors
this is what Intel called pneuma
um they it's a generic term but
non-uniform memory architecture in most
bios settings you'll see a tweak where
you can set up memory so you have the
same access speed to both of those Banks
or you can take advantage of the faster
speed
my next slide here has a whole bunch of
specs on the processor Generations I'm
putting it up here basically to show
that
three different generations of
processors from 2012 to 2013 to 2014 the
latest being the Haswell
these numbers have been going up a
little but you'll notice clock rates
went from just over three gigahertz to
3.7 they've gone up a little process has
shrunk in technology
the qpis have scaled up in speed but
most significantly we're getting more
cores we went from eight cores in the
Sandy Bridge class of chips up to 18
available in the Haswell class chips
today
that's nice to get all those cores most
of these other numbers are just keeping
pace so we're not hitting a lot of clock
rate increases just there are more cores
the caches are getting bigger but things
are scaling out this way we're not
getting faster it's too expensive to go
quicker
in terms of choosing
the The Guiding rule these days is you
look at between one and one and a half
Hadoop tasks per core base and per
physical core so assume you have like
one thread running on One Core
the one to one and a half gives you some
Headroom for other processes because we
normally enable Intel's hyper threading
which lets us get kind of a parallel
thing where we can use the execution
units for multiple threads and the
hardware schedules
hyper threading works for most jobs
under Hadoop and Spark if you're dealing
with highly optimized code it usually
doesn't make a difference because if the
code was written to take advantage of
the process or architect like some some
of the lower level numpy stuff hyper
threading probably won't help you a lot
um
the general rule in Hadoop
configurations I'm talking about
processors here but we tie back to disks
we Hadoop really wants to see one core
and one spindle because most of the
Hadoop workloads are a Hadoop job
reading a file from disk and doing
something to it and writing the results
out again so if you have a nice one core
one disc balance it kind of optimizes
your throughput you can throw more
spindles in there Hadoop really won't
use them or take advantage of them if
you're running Empower which is
clutter's SQL query on top of Hadoop
it's fast it's written in C plus plus it
flies it can handle a lot more spindles
on cores so machines designed or
optimized to lean towards Impala tend to
have more memory more spindles more
cores
for spark it depends on what you're
running for the back
of the back spark itself likes the one
thread or one partition per CPU model on
the disk side it's mostly memory
intensive so it's not hitting the
spindles a lot when it's running and the
storage setup depends on whether you're
using hdfs or some other storage array
at the back
in general this may seem
counter-intuitive but in general when
you're dealing with Hadoop and Spark
a faster processor with less cores is
actually better than more cores if you
throw these 18 core processors in the
Box I can only put 16 spindles in there
today
so I have two 18 core processors 16
spindles I have way more processor than
I need we're actually putting less cores
and cranking the clock weight on the
processors a little more
that's a common Trend you'll see in the
processor design
other than that
you kind of have to Benchmark it's
really hard to give you any good
guidelines but most people are following
these guidelines
memory
DDR3 versus ddr4 that's pretty much the
decision these days the newer generation
machines are using ddr4 you can get
memory in terms of 8 16 32 64 gigs 128
gigs is on the market now but it's silly
expensive
The Sweet Spot for pricing is somewhere
between 16 and 32 at the server Market
it actually depends on current spot
prices in the dram Market
a key thing for performance is we
normally balance the memory channel so
if I go back to that processor layout I
had four channels to memory I want four
dimms for every processor so I'm better
off with four 16 gig dimms than I am
with 232s if I have 232s it'll work but
I'm only using two memory channels
the sad thing about this is your
temptation is to put in 232s and then
upgrade later unfortunately it doesn't
work that way so we'll often put in four
sixteens and then if I want to add more
memory later I'll put in four more 16s
just one of those doctors in the
hardware this stuff's all server class
memory so it's normally ECC uh checked
it's usually registered there are tweaks
at the BIOS level in Dell servers to
handle some of the optimization of the
memory handling behind the scenes
for disk choices behind the scenes your
main choices are three and a half inch
drives two and a half inch drives or
SATA solid state disks the three and a
half inch drives they're up to six
terabytes now so in the machine I showed
you the picture of earlier I can
actually put in in the current
generation r730 I can put in 16 six
terabyte spindles
if somebody really wants storage density
you can do that the mainstream stuff is
somewhere between three and four I think
the three terabytes are the optimal
pricing but the four terabytes are
moving fast that's what everybody is
using on new servers six terabytes is
pushing it for Hadoop it goes back to
that fault Zone if I put
12 6 terabyte drives in a machine
that's 72 terabytes if my machine fails
that's a lot of data that has to get
replicated in the cluster and it can
have a huge production impact so again
the trend had been bigger bigger bigger
nodes things are now leveling off and
people are going back to wider clusters
with smaller nodes
because the technology has been moving
so quick for connections Saturn SAS
doesn't really matter the SAS stuff is
slightly faster it does a better job of
handling multiple requests to the disk
because it can reorder them but in
general Hadoop is doing large sequential
i o transfers so it's mostly saving data
reading data it's not random access
six gigabit or six gigabyte per second
drives are just the the standard
interface right now but
three is more than enough the spinning
the spinning platters actually can
transfer data fast enough to handle this
out of 6.0 stuff ssds can two and a half
inch drives you can get more spindles in
a machine
but the drives aren't as big so you'll
see 800 gig and 1.2 terabyte two and a
half inch drives today I tend to use
those for configurations where I know
I'm going to be running in power doing a
lot of interactive query on data if it's
just pure batch processing there's not a
lot of bang for the buck and the two and
a half inch drives because they cost a
little more the saddest stuff
um it's expensive I'll tell you right
now it's really fast but nobody's going
to build an entire cluster Hadoop
cluster out of Saturn SSD drives
I just realized SATA ssds I meant to say
SSD is there the ssds are fast but they
cost more and the price performance just
isn't there it's like it
it works out as something like 10 times
the performance for 100 times the price
it's just not worth it we do use them
right now for operating systems and
stuff that's scratch space they do have
strategic uses in a couple places in the
machine but not for the mainstream
storage they're also not as
deterministic the ssds have this garbage
collection thing where they reallocate
sectors every so often and you can get
weird latencies at times I'm doing a lot
of work in that area to see if that's
changing but at least right now I'm not
using ssds for Hadoop
um quick touch here I think I'm running
to time am I
how we doing
we've got a couple of minutes
um trade-offs here I'm again I'm trying
to cover a lot of things at once but a
lot of what we're juggling is the
spindle core storage depth optimization
the slide has all the details here
here's what it looks like in practice
if I were to take a cluster and I'm
comparing this is a model called the
c8000 which lets us do very deep storage
I'm comparing a a setup that's using 12
spindle discs with uh three terabyte
drives versus six spindles and three
terabytes so I've put more spindles in
each machine and I'm looking at the
scaling across my cluster so I have
three scales here the gray line is the
number of cores in the cluster so as I
go to more nodes in my cluster using 16
core xeons my core scale is pretty
linearly
but the values here for storage in iops
one versus storage and iops 2 are
comparing the six versus 12 spindles and
by making that decision how many
spindles I'm putting in the machine and
how big the drives are I'm setting
essentially the slope of the growth
curve for the storage in the machines
so what happens with these two red lines
here is as I scale out the cluster it's
always a linear scaling but I'm
controlling how much storage I add as I
add nodes this is an important decision
because a lot of people work back work
to their total data size and then go
back and say here's how we're going to
scale it but you have to remember that
as you're scaling you're not just adding
storage you're adding storage and
compute so things things go up the same
thing for i o operations per second they
also scale and again you're controlling
to a certain extent the scaling rate by
making that early decision we have
customers that have gone out rolled out
a cluster and only put like six drives
in the machine in their plan for
expansion is they're going to go put
back and put another six drives into the
machine later that's not a bad strategy
the one got you with that is apart from
having to physically touch the machines
after installed which gets expensive
just because you got to send a person in
um but the the trick to that strategy is
when you go back and touch all those
machines and add extra disk you still
have to do a rebalancing and Hadoop but
I've seen people do that particularly
because if you put which is common these
days 12 three terabyte spindles 36
terabytes of data per disk if it's a
small cluster if you've got a 10 node
cluster
ten percent of your data is on every one
of those machines after replication it's
more like a third so if you lose a
machine
you're not out of luck the data is
replicated with the cluster fault Zone
gets big so I'm seeing people use
smaller data nodes unless they know the
cluster is very big
that's the scaling networking I do need
to touch on this I talked about it on
the beginning picture it's basically a
tree there's nothing fancy going on here
we take the nodes we bring them up to
the top of a rack and we use topper rack
switches and every node has a connection
to the switch at the top of the rack
every switch at the top of the rack has
a connection to an aggregate switch at
the top
that's the basic model it's a tree this
works for clusters getting into hundreds
of nodes if you want to build a thousand
node cluster that those top switches get
saturated and there's some other tricks
we use but this is going to work for a
fairly large cluster uh what I do what
most of my architectures is I run two 10
gig links to the top of rack to two
alternate switches and I use a feature
called VLT which is a form of stacking
we can connect those two switches so
that they act as one logical switch but
if one of the switches fails the other
one you carry the load so I build a
certain amount of redundancy for a
switch failure in the cluster
going up to the aggregation switches the
uplinks are 40 gigs each and each one of
those switches has two links to two
alternate aggregate switches so I have I
have from each rack I have four 40
gigabit network connections going up to
the cluster aggregation switch which
covers me if I have a switch failure I
lose half my bandwidth but my cluster
doesn't go down if a cable fails I lose
some of my bandwidth and I've got the
bandwidth if everything's working I can
use that bandwidth so that's the basic
model the next slide here has I think it
says what I just said a couple of points
this stuff is all Layer Two switching so
there's no fancy tricky routing frankly
our home firewall does more packing
inspection on it on packets than we do
in Hadoop because we want it to go fast
so switch characteristics a lot of line
rate switching no latency there deep
buffers because you can have a whole
bunch of machines connecting to one VLT
is that stacking thing that lets us pair
up switches we do 40 gig uplinks 10 gig
is the 10 gigabit Ethernet is the norm
for clusters gigabit you can do today 40
gigabit for all the machines is too
expensive and the software doesn't use
it
uh
in the wild
just to give you a perspective I talked
about that Appliance configuration but
in terms of what our customers run the
vast majority of them are running that
r720xd it was the previous generation
um to use socket server we have a bunch
of customers running that dual socket
they typically run 12 cores I got five
left oh wow I'm on ahead of time
um mostly 12 cores and an awful lot of
people running the 24 two and a half
inch drives
um there's another model c8000 it's
popular for really what I would call
Deep applications with Hadoop uh the
Hadoop is for people that use their data
you'll hear us saying that it's the
cheapest storage system out there and I
don't agree there's cheaper ways to
store data reliably but if you want to
process the data you can't beat Hadoop
because every time you add storage ad
processing the c8000 with 16 three and a
half inch drives four terabytes each is
pretty popular I can actually do a
variation of that with uh with over 20
drives on it it's really deep storage
it's used a lot for archival there are
some people that are bringing in logs or
machine logs are just generally
transaction history and it's archival
they got regulatory reasons that they
have to keep it array for keep it around
for three and five years but they really
only process it once they do one pass
through the data they roll it up or do
extract some Fields they're interested
in the rest of it's just archival you
can do deep storage there are some older
models we've used
a lot of our bigger customers have
repurposed machines the 6100s and the
2100s these were originally built for
web serving so some customers have taken
those machines repurpose them to Hadoop
clusters and replace their front-end web
application machines with neural models
so you'll see a lot of this sort of
thing happening you know machines that
come on the market that are the last
generation they actually either come on
the used Market or within a company they
just repurposed them
there's another machine we have built
for cloud computing it gets used quite a
bit for Hadoop but it's actually a
really bad balance machine we've had
customers use this but this core spindle
rate just doesn't have enough spindles
you can put 16 cores and only handle six
drives not a great setup for Hadoop
r620s are popular in one U there is a
religious war in the Hadoop world over
should you use 1u versus 2u servers for
Hadoop a lot of people are actually
going in the trend of a smaller server
and more servers
in terms of pricing the 1u servers when
you put enough storage in them they
start working out to be more expensive
than the 2u servers that can have a lot
of disk space in that single node so
people are using one you but I wouldn't
say it dominates the market
so I've had a crash course in Hardware
so I need to I need to wrap up in terms
of q a i mean we could start q a now but
there's things I haven't touched here I
haven't touched gpus grab me later if
you want to talk about gpus it can be
done not many people are doing it
um if you're doing tons of data
streaming
um you know there are special
configurations we want to use and I
think
one of my pet projects is to look at a
machine called the Dell vertex it's kind
of a side project
it's kind of a blade chassis that was
built for small and remote offices
and it's got a bunch of processors and a
bunch of disks so it's kind of nice as a
killer killer data science workstation
it's like production grade server that
you could fit in a normal office
environment so I'm going to play with
that but I haven't talked about it today
so thank you
for attending and you know any questions
here as we're wrapping up I'm
comments about
like cies
yeah it's a good point
so in a half hour it's hard to fit
everything in but we have a set of
machines that do support pcie ssds so
these are a flash storage device that
literally sits on the PCI bus they are
fast
um for Hadoop itself they don't make a
lot of sense right now because Hadoop
has this Brute Force approach that it
assumes reading and writing discs you
know always that's the spark on the
other hand is evolving with the file
system called tachyon to have a
hierarchical storage I think those pcie
ssds are going to come into play there
because you have a memory hierarchy have
cash main memory
persistent storage is Flash and spindles
in the back end and you have software
that can manage that hierarchy really
interesting stuff there
but today for Hadoop they just they
don't pay
I'm stealing somebody else's time so
I'm gonna wrap up here and if you want
to ask questions uh just come up and
grab me I can talk about this stuff all
day long